hey what's up guys my name is HN and
welcome back to my OpenGL series so
today we're gonna be talking all about
textures in OpenGL and we're gonna start
by defining what exactly a texture is so
when most people think of textures they
really just think of having an image on
a 3d object in a game it doesn't have to
be a 3d object of course but some kind
of image that you've created in
something like Photoshop or paint or
paint or whatever having that on some
kind of surface in your graphical
application that is essentially what a
texture is or at least that's how most
people actually kind of think of a
texture now beyond that textures can
really be a lot more than just what I
just described textures can be used
really for a lot of things and we'll
discover that when we get into some
pretty complicated graphics techniques
but for now I just want I just want you
to think about a texture as essentially
an image that we can use when we're
rendering something so what I can
actually do is design or create some
kind of image whether that be a
photograph or maybe just a squiggly line
on a canvas or maybe like a kind of
solid color or something like that
anything like that
I can create any image file on my
computer and then I can actually upload
it to my GPUs memory and use that in my
shader for whatever kind of drawing I'm
doing now this might be something as
simple as just drawing a rectangle in
our OpenGL program the contained that is
actually rendering that texture so that
we can see the texture in our game or it
might be something a lot more
complicated like using kind of
pre-calculated mathematical values that
are baked into our texture and then
being able to sample them in our shader
so that we can do some cool lighting
effects but for now is just going to be
getting an image from our computer onto
a surface in our OpenGL application so
let's take a look at what we've got here
so if we launch our application right
now just so that we can remember well
we're actually at you'll see that we
just had this kind of rectangle with a
pulsating color now what we're going to
do today is actually draw a texture on
that rectangle instead of this kind of
solid color now if I look at my actual
directory for this OpenGL
program I've made this resources folder
and inside there I've made a folder
called textures which just has a single
image and it's gonna be this cheddar
logo that I have here this is what we're
actually going to draw on top of that
rectangle that we have in our program so
how do we do that how do we go from
having a physical kind of PNG file on
our computer to actually being able to
sample it in our shader so that we can
draw it on the screen how does that how
does that work well step one is we need
to load that image somehow into our CPU
memory right so in this case it's a PNG
now I'm not gonna get into how games use
textures and what formats that all that
will say for the game engine series PNG
is aren't really used in game engines
most game engines have their own texture
format for various reasons but for now
just because again this is all about
loading opengl we do have a PNG image
file so what we need to do is load that
somehow now PNG format isn't
particularly complicated but there are a
few kind of there are a few different
pixel formats inside there as well as
primarily the option of having a
compressed PNG as well and there's a
bunch of decoding that we actually need
to do to get the data out so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna use a library
for that and specifically we're gonna
use something called STP image which is
a very very small
that's all we're gonna do we're gonna
get it from github in a second here but
all we need really is one file and we're
gonna use that to actually load the PNG
now when I say load the PNG what I mean
is we give it a file path so this is my
file on my computer and what it's going
to do is give us basically a pointer to
a buffer of rgba pixels which is what we
actually want to then take to the next
step which is going to be taking that
pixel array and uploading it to our GPU
and the way we do that of course is
through opengl because opengl is our
graphics specification so we use opengl
to then send that data into the GPU as a
texture once we've done that we can
modify our shader to actually read that
texture when it's drawing so the pixel
shader the fragment shader is going to
read from that texture memory and
actually work out which pixel should be
which color as per that texture and
that's what that's what will happen when
we actually draw that rectangle of ours
so just to recap overall
and we'll there are some detailed steps
kind of in between that will address
definitely but that is the gist of it
right we load our image we create a
texture in OpenGL we then have to bind
that texture when it's time to render we
modify our shader to all sort of kind of
bind to that texture slot that we've
bound our texture to and we also sample
that texture in our shader and when we
draw a rectangle we should see the
texture so let's just go ahead and write
some code so the first thing that we
really need to do is load this image
somehow into our CPU memory so that we
can send it to OpenGL so over here what
I've got is a github repository which
I'll link in the description below and
inside this kind of STB library which
single file public domain libraries for
c c++ so you can use this completely
free there's something called STP image
and really there's just this one file
that's all we need
I'm gonna open that file I'm going to
click on raw here and just to make this
really simple for myself I'm just going
to ctrl a ctrl C so I'm copying all the
text inside this file here and back
inside my project I'm going to make a
new source file here now I'm gonna make
a folder called defender and inside
there a folder called STB on the score
image just so that I can kind of know
that this isn't only my code I'll make a
header file called STV underscore image
H and delete everything from this file
and just paste in what I've copied and
you can see it's about seven and a half
thousand lines of code yeah ok cool now
if you actually read this file this is
what you should do when you're when you
get new file from the internet and your
libraries and all that
it basically says pretty simply do this
write define SCB image implementation
before you include this file in one see
your simple plus file to create the
implementation ok so it should look like
this it even like gives you an example
right so what we need to do to actually
compile this code once and once only is
we basically add a new item I'm gonna
add a CPP file I'm gonna call this STV
image now CPR score image dot CPP I'm
going to include STV image dot age but
before I do that as it says over here
I'm going to define STP image
implementation and that's all I need to
do and if I hit ctrl f7 is going to
compile all of that SUV image code there
we go
done simple as that now the next step is
going to be to create a texture class
for ourselves that we can kind of
organized over all of our codes I'm
going to add a new item it's going to be
a header file we're going to call it
texture dot H I'm also going to add a
new item which is going to be our secret
B file of course textured LCVP going to
include texture H in here and this is
just going to be now a texture class
I'll include the renderer in here so
that we have access to OpenGL and
everything we need and we can start with
creating our texture class so inside
here I'll make hit render ID as we have
for pretty much everything I'm also
going to keep track of the actual file
path about texture I'm going to define
an unsigned char which is going to be
our local buffer this is just going to
be local storage for the texture and
then finally we also need the width and
the height and the bits per pixel of the
actual texture all right cool
and then inside here public I'm going to
make a constructor which is just going
to taking a path that's all we need I'll
make it the structure as well so we can
destroy everything when we need to a
function called bind and unbind and
that's pretty much it now I will make
some like helpers here like get with for
example which will just return the width
and height just in case we want to get
that later but in general I like to cut
about these things as I actually need
them instead of pre defining all my
class because otherwise it takes quite a
while to just think about well I wonder
what I want this class to have when you
can just extend it later now bind I'm
gonna change a little bit I'm actually
going to put an unsigned in slot equals
0 over here so what this is is an
optional parameter if you don't specify
it it will be 0 which basically allows
you to specify the slot that you want to
find a texture to now in OpenGL we have
various slots that we can find textures
to and the reason that exists is because
we have the ability to actually bind
more than one texture at once so on
Windows typically in like with modern
GPUs you have about 32 texture slots or
as on mobile like on an Android or an
iPhone you might have like 8 for example
again this really depends on the actual
GPU that you have and their
implementation of
Jill you can always ask OpenGL hey how
many Texas law still I have but just to
give you a rough ballpark on went on
like on modern GPUs you have about 32 or
mobile GPUs you may have eight that's
roughly what it will be but of course
you can just consult your platform to
find out so I'm going to right click on
texture and using visual assist just
create all of the method implementations
that's just going to create these
implementations for my constructor and
all of my methods I'm going to in my
constructor assign file path to be path
when I set basically initialize most of
these things local buffer will set to
null pointer width and height to zero
and you should really try and do these
in the same water they're defined in mr.
pixels bits per pixel are set to zero
and it looks pretty good so the only
thing I really did was actually I did do
it in order and right here was the first
thing zero alright cool so there we go
I've got some I'm initializing all of my
variables and then what I'm gonna do
here is just start loading the texture
somebody's jail call GL gen textures
swim generate one texture and assign it
to render OID I'm then going to go ahead
and bind it so we bind it by just
calling GL bind texture now we specify
kind of like what we do with like our
vertex buffer well when where we
actually bind it we specify kind of
which what kind of buffer it is or what
slot with running it to so in this case
is going to be a GL texture 2d because
it's just a two-dimensional texture we
might talk about the different texture
types in the future when we get to them
renderer ID is the texture that we're
binding now let's go ahead and actually
load our image so to do that we need to
include STP image so I'm just going to
type in include as tip now of course
this is going to be in vendor slash STP
image does this to be image if I was
actually properly setting up this
project I might have actually included
the vendor folder in the include parts
for my compiler so that I weren't after
the kinda vendor but this is fine now
actually before we do all this let's
actually load the image now the first
thing I want to do is type in STV I set
flip vertically onload now the reason we
need to do this
and then I'm going to just set this to 1
so what this does is actually flips our
texture vertically so it makes it upside
down the reason we need to do this is
because OpenGL actually expects our text
to kind of start at the bottom left not
the top left right so the bottom left in
OpenGL is zero zero now typically when
we load images like PNG for example
stores it in scan lines kind of from the
top of the image to the bottom of the
image so we need to actually flip it on
load this really does depend on your
texture format so definitely take a look
at this for our use case for our PNG
here we do need to flip it so just if
you see that your textures upside down
or whatever you can play with this flag
to make sure that you get it the right
way up okay the next thing we're going
to do is assign M local buffer which is
our local storage for our texture to BST
bi load now we're gonna have to specify
a file name which is gonna be path dot c
string then we have pointers to X Y and
channels which is just going to store
all of our actual width and height and
all that so we've already variables for
this we just pass in the memory address
and what this scpi load function will do
is actually write the width and height
and the bits per pixel or whatever into
those actual variables for us so but
we're passing pointers to these
variables so that this function can
actually write to them and desired
channels is kind of how many desired
channels we have so we want RGB a so
that's four so I just want to type in
four like that okay so once we've got
this we've actually got all of our
texture data inside this local buffer
here what I need to do now is set up
some actual settings I guess for our
texture that we've just generated here
so the way that we set any texture
parameters we called GL text parameter
and then the type of data with runstats
so this is gonna be an eye for integer
so the first parameter here is the
target which is texture 2d the next slot
is the actual parameter name which in
this case is going to be GL texture min
built up so this is the minification
filter this is how our texture will
actually be resampled down if it needs
to be rendered smaller than it is kind
of per pixel we're gonna have an
in-depth episode on all of these kind of
texture parameters because like dealing
with MIT maps and kind of minification
and magnification filtering and like you
know edge clamping all that is it kind
of a big topic then I don't want to just
squeeze it in here so we will talk about
this stuff in more detail in the future
don't worry but for now you think could
just kind of use these settings and I'll
explain them as I go so this we're gonna
set to geo linear which
just going to linearly resample
everything so we'll kind of still look
ok it's not going to snap at the nearest
pixel which is what gel nearest would do
we also have to specify the
magnification filter which is if we
actually kind of render our texture on
an area that is larger in pixels than
the actual texture size so it needs to
scale it up we also need to specify the
clamp modes so Jill corrected gel text
parameter I geo texture 2d gel texture
wrap now I call them clamp most but
they're just they're really wrapper eyes
so wrap s the horizontal wrap so we
wanted to clamp which means that we we
wanted to basically not extend the area
the other option is tiling so we don't
want to talk about textures here so s
and T is kind of like X&Y but for
textures and these four parameters you
need to specify if you don't specify
these four parameters you're just gonna
get it like a black texture which is a
little bit annoying because you kind of
expect them to maybe be on sensible
defaults by default but they're not so
make sure you specify these four
otherwise you may and probably will get
a black texture but of course that does
depend on your OpenGL implementation
okay cool
next step is going to be to actually
give OpenGL the data that we've read in
yellow so we've got a bunch of pixel
data inside and local buffer let's
actually send it now to OpenGL so the
way we do that is via an OpenGL called
called gel text image 2d so the target
is going to be GL texture 2d the level
this is this is at this point you
probably want to read the documentation
to figure out what all of these are a
lot of these are completely you're all
irrelevant to us I'm gonna kind of skip
past that we will look at advanced
textures in the future so we'll cover
them then but for now we're gonna levels
be zero because this is not a
multi-level texture internal format is
going to be GL rgba that's how opengl is
going to see our actual format RGBA
not the format of the data we're
supplying but how we want open shell to
deal with our data
internal format vs. format is a huge
topic in itself which will probably even
dedicate an episode to because people
confuse that all the time but internal
format which is the first format that's
how OpenGL will store a texture data
whereas format is the texture data is
the format of the data you're providing
OpenGL with so in other words the format
of M local buffer now in recent
implementations of OpenGL you should
actually call this GLG ba8
okay so you should be specifying the
actual
per channel which is how you want OpenGL
to store your texture so geogebra is
kind of deprecated it will still work on
most implementations but you do
technically the correct modern OpenGL
way to do this is actually to specify a
number here which says how many bits you
have per channel
all right so width is going to be M
width which is what we read in from our
s TV I load function then we pass in M
height for the height of our texture
border we definitely don't want a border
so is your pixel border so format is
that's like the second format so that's
the format of the data we're supplying
in geology ba is what it is we don't use
numbers here the type is the type of
data so unsigned byte right so we have
jail RGB a and each one of these
channels is an unsigned byte and then
finally we have appointed to pixels now
you can make this you can actually pass
in a null pointer Heroes as your or
something like that if you're not ready
at this stage to actually give up and
share your data what that means is that
you're just allocating space on the GPU
because it knows how much space it needs
but you're not actually providing it
with data now we already have the data
so I'm just gonna pass in m local buffer
just like that alright great and that's
really all we need so what I want to do
now is unbind our texture by just
calling GL buy into texture 0 could also
called the unbind texture function well
we of course need to specify what we
want to unbind such your texture 2d
since I've got this code here just going
to copy and paste this into unbind as
well because that's really all we need
cool so now what we can do is if m local
buffer right so if this buffer does
actually contain data when use scpi
image free to actually free this local
buffer now more complicated setups you
may want to retain a copy of the pixel
data on your CPU because you might want
to sample it or do something whatever
you may want to do with that data so
that's totally perfectly ok as well
totally perfectly okay that's also kind
of acceptable right so you may want to
have something is something in the
constructor that's like you know keep
keep local data around or something like
that we really care about that so I'm
just freeing it but that's why I kind of
made it a member variable and local
buffer in case you kind of want to store
it and that's it now finally over here
inside our destructor
we could delete the data man we've
already freed the data in the console in
the constructor so we don't have to deal
with that here but we do need to
actually jail delete textures to delete
our actual texture from the GPU
when this object yes tourism gets
destroyed so we'll just chill delay
textures and passing that renderer ID
now bind is an interesting function
because we already know how to bind
textures it's really just this right but
what we can do here is actually specify
a texture slot and we do that by typing
in GL call GL active texture now active
texture takes in an integer which is
Israeli jail enum which is going to be
wish Act which Texas law we're currently
activating so again this is kind of like
the whole same machine selecting thing
in open channel we basically say hey I'm
gonna make GL active texture slot 16
that means that the next texture that I
bind will be bound to slot 16 until I
call GL active texture again with a
different slot so in this case the way
that we specify sloths is we use enums
right so chill checked a deal gel
texture 0 like that is the very first
slot now we have texture 1 2 extra 2 or
whatever if you actually look at what
these are equal to they are of course
just integers and they go all the way up
to 31 right so you have 32 texture slots
now this does not mean that your
platform supports that made textures
it's just 32 happens to be the maximum
that OpenGL that the OpenGL
specification allows your platform as I
said mobile may have like 8 so you
should query and find out how many you
have if you are gonna use this many
texture slots with you probably usually
won't be unless you're making a really
big game because there are ways to kind
of you know reuse textures and we'll
talk about that later but anyway we have
all the attach these texture slots now
in this case we are specifying an
unsigned int now this will be something
like 0 through 231 so what you can do is
just type in geo texture 0 plus slot and
then it will add the slot because if you
look at these definitions you can see
that they are actually consecutive
numbers right they just they do just
count up so that's our entire texture
class that is all that we need to
actually give OpenGL our texture and for
us to render and all of that alright so
I knew this was going to be a long
episode but let's keep going and let's
actually see something on the screen
because that is the goal for today's
video
so back inside application let's set all
this up so I'm going to at any point
really just type in texture texture I'm
going to give it the path which is res
slash text
/ sure no logo dot PNG I'm going to
include texture up the top because I
haven't done that yet and scrolling back
down I'm going to bind my texture no I'm
not gonna pass in a parameter which
means it's gonna be equal to zero by
default one thing I need to do by the
way with my shaders before I forget is
we need to first of all fix out this
awful error I made last time when in
which I passed in and well basically I
make this map have an unsigned ends and
I just I use unsigned and a bit too much
it seems because this get uniform
location function
I even check to see if the location is
negative one here because that's totally
valid that just means that it couldn't
find our uniform but I'm assigning it to
an unsigned in here which is obviously
never going to be negative one so all of
this should be an int not an unsigned
int when you're dealing with uniform
locations and OpenGL the type is a
32-bit integer okay
so int and this should also be int and
if we go back to our header file this
should be int because that's how uniform
cash and also this should be int and I
think that's all the ends if I compile
there's hope little work and yet we're
all good okay that's one thing I need to
clear up now one thing that we need to
do is we need to actually tell our
shader which texture slot to sample from
and the way we do that is via a uniform
now this isn't really an integer slot
it's something called a sampler slot and
this is a bit hazy and a bit weird
basically what we need to do is send an
integer uniform to our shader and that
integer is the slot that we've bound a
texture to that we want to sample from
and then we in the shader code we can
actually use that sampler or that
integer that we've passed in to actually
sample that texture and do what we want
with it
okay so that's how that works so to do
that we need to write another shader
uniform function here which is going to
be called set uniform one eye which is
for integer and then we take in int
value like that I'll copy and paste this
one F function and replace this with int
and that's pretty much it right just
make sure you replace uniform one half
here with one eye okay cool back to
application
now that we have this we can actually
set that up as well so shader set
uniform one eye we're gonna call this
uniform u underscore texture and we're
gonna set it to zero okay because we
bound our texture to slot zero so that
zero needs to match whatever you're
passing in here five had passed in like
texture bind to or something to slot to
we would be passing into here
okay let's undo that alright cool so
there we go pretty simple stuff now one
thing we haven't done is actually credit
something called texture coordinates so
what we need to do is actually use
something called a texture coordinate
system to tell our geometry that we're
rendering which part of the texture to
sample from so our pixel shader goes
through and renters and rasterizes our
rectangle right just goes through the
rectangle and draws every pixel the
pixel shader of the fragment shader is
responsible for determining the color of
each pixel so what we actually need to
do is somehow when it's up to rendering
a certain pixel tell it to sample a
certain area of our texture to retrieve
what color the pixel should be right if
you think about it's actually kind of
simple it's not too complicated to
understand hopefully this makes sense if
you don't drop a coin below and I may I
might make a detailed kind of in-depth
video on how the rasterization works and
how texture sampling works and all that
stuff but basically what I'm saying is
we need to say that hey the bottom left
of our rectangle on our screen is like
coordinate zero zero and the top like
right is the other end of the texture
which in OpenGL terms is going to be one
one okay because textures don't really
literally tie textures to certain sizes
or we don't tie texture coordinates to a
certain resolution because the texture
could be 64 by 64 it could be a thousand
twenty four five thousand twenty four
could be like fifty seven by nineteen it
could be anything right so what we need
to do is basically specify for each
vertex that we have of our rectangle
what area of the texture it should be
and then the fragment shader will
interpolate between that so that if
we're rendering a pixel that's like
halfway between two vertices it will
pick the texture coordinate it's like
you know halfway between the two
vertices plus a fella so to do that
if we come over here to our positions we
know this one is the bottom-left so
that's going to be zero by zero I'm
adding another vector basically I'm
adding two more floats to each vertex
here which are our texture coordinates
now this is going to be one point zero
zero point zero because it's the right
side right so zero point five F is the
rightmost edge of our actual rectangle
and so I'm setting that to be one which
means sample from the right side of the
texture this is going to be one point
zero one one point zero as well 0.5 0.5
is the top right and that's what we're
also matching without extra coordinate
and then finally we have zero and one
point zero now we need to add this to
our vertex buffer layout again with our
API it's really easy we just do this
layout to push two more floats right
that's it that's all we need to do we
also need to actually expand this vertex
buffer to contain these extra things
right so now instead of having two
floats per vertex we actually have four
floats per vertex so we'll increase this
default and finally we need to go into
our shader and basically rewrite the
whole thing so in our vertex shader we
now take in a texture coordinate at
location one which is a vector I'll call
it the text cord or something like that
and now I faced with something a little
bit new we need to get this texture
coordinate into our actual fragment
shader because check this out the way
that we're going to actually sample our
texture is as I said earlier by using
that sampler 2d uniform right so sampler
today you want to store texture which is
the uniform that we set over here we set
it to be zero right
so we need to sample this somehow and
that's this you touch uniform and the
way that we do that is we actually work
out the color this returns a vector for
which is that kind of like our text
color I'll just write this out for you
guys text color is going to be texture
the texture that we're sampling which is
you texture and then we specify those
texture coordinates right so how do we
actually specify our texture coordinates
because they're in the vertex shader so
the way that we kind of send data
between the vertex and the fragment
shaders by something called a varying
now in modern OpenGL this is kind of the
in and out system that we were already
used to similarly to how we can actually
input data into the vertex
typing in in and also how put data from
the fragment shader by having it out we
can also output data from the vertex
shader into the fragment shader and the
way that we do that is we type in out
now this is going to be a vector of
course it's our texture coordinate and
I'll call this V underscore text chord V
sense for varying which is what this is
called
and then I'll assign V Tech score to be
the text chord that we take in from our
vertex buffer and then similarly in the
fragment shader I'm going to type in in
back to V underscore text quad just like
that and I'm going to use that text cord
over here so that we actually sample
that specific texture coordinate because
remember this fragment shader runs for
every pixel so we need to know the
precise location in the texture to
actually look up so that we can draw
that pixel from the texture in our
actual scene and that's what this whole
sampling thing is about again I'm sure
we'll discuss this in the future in more
depth ok cool so now instead of
assigning this to you color I'm gonna
assign this to text color which is our
actual texture look up color and
everything looks pretty good to me
now I did write a lot of code and I'm
not sure if this will work as I haven't
even run this program once but let's
just have five and who knows maybe this
will just be beautiful okay so we get a
nice little OpenGL eric here if we look
at the actual console we can see it's
1280 this is because this is not gel
clamp is supposed to be teal clamp to
edge in more modern versions so we'll
just set this to be GL clamp to edge now
one other thing that I noticed when I
was debugging this as well is the local
buffer was actually null which means
we're not loading this incorrectly so
let me just refresh this and figure out
what's going on with our actual texture
so if I so if I just refresh this it
doesn't look like we've actually got the
textures in here for some reason and
that's of course because this results
this folder wasn't inside my project
directory make sure you put it into your
project directory and now if I hit this
refresh button you'll see we have
textures in here and all that this
should work better now let's hit f5 take
- all right beautiful so we see the
channel logo now it looks like absolute
trash why does my logo look like trash
well I don't know if I should end this
on a cliffhanger or if I should actually
finish this I know why it's not working
obviously but
this could be fun you know what I
usually would leave this on a
cliffhanger but this is just such a
beautifully long episode that I think we
might as well finish it it's because I
don't have blending enabled and of
course as you saw that channel logo did
have areas of transparency so there's no
transparency being rendered right now
it's not blending at all that's why it's
coming out weird to fix that we just
need to set up a blending function and
enable blending there will be an episode
on blending and transparency in the
future hundred percent guarantee that
let's just make this work now the time
being so if I close this and I go back
into my application or in fact into my
render I think did I do kind of OpenGL
set up stuff in the render right I think
I did no I didn't okay so we'll do this
in the application file for now what I'm
going to do is scroll up here once I
have my OpenGL context it's kind of part
of the open jelly initialization I guess
I'm gonna set up GL blend func so I'm
gonna set a blending function and this
is gonna be GL sauce alpha mozzarella GL
source alpha and GL one minus source
alpha so what we're doing here is we're
basically defining how Open GL is going
to blend alpha pixels right so this
really does require its own episode but
essentially we're saying that for the
source take the sauce alpha and when
you're trying to render something on top
of that take one - that source alpha
which will basically get the difference
of that so it's just really just it
really is just a mathematical equation
equation like literally 1 minus the
source alpha is what the destination
alpha is going to end up being again
episode on that in the future and then
finally we do need to also enable
blending by calling GL enable and then
GL blend okay and you can do this in any
water doesn't really matter I kind of
like doing it in this order just because
we enable blending and then we kind of
set up the blend function let's hit a 5
and we should see a beautiful channel
logo and you can see there we go now of
course it does look a bit stretched
because the rectangle tool for rendering
is not square because our window is not
square and this is kind of based on
window positions but if you can kind of
get over there you can
we have a beautiful channel logo
rendering and that is how we use
textures in OpenGL if you have any
questions about textures that you want
answered leave a comment below because I
am gonna make a lot of related videos to
textures in the future textures are a
really big deal of graphics programming
and all of that obviously so we are
gonna talk a lot more about them in the
future other than that I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did you can
hit that like button and let me know
what your thoughts are about all this
stuff in the comment section below as
always huge thank you to all the patreon
supporters that let me make videos like
this for all of you if you want to
support this series and see more
episodes and get videos early patreon a
conference at the channel and I will see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]